foreign
[Music]
we are going to we're going to play
we're gonna play one D4 so the last
maybe 10 15 games we've been alternating
between E4 and D4
if you're not a D4 player that doesn't
mean you should be upset that I'm
playing something you don't play it's an
opportunity to learn about new positions
and I think that can be exciting
we're going to play Mainline D4 stuff D4
and C4
let's see what our opponent throws at us
G6 okay so grunfelder King's Indian
grunfelder King's Indian
now of course there are a million moves
already in this position but let's stick
to the main line and play Knight C3
most people at this level don't play the
gruenfield yeah indeed
black plays the king's Indian of course
our move is E4 main line and after D6 we
reach sword of the first uh tabia atavia
is a position that is usually reached in
an opening and the tabia is a position
where there are a lot of deviations and
it's basically a branching out point
that almost everybody reaches in a
certain opening so this is the first
branching out point where we can decide
on a line there are 10 or 15 viable
Kings Indian lines from this position
and I will give you the full menu after
the game but the line that I recommend
to most students and people who are
looking for a good underrated and poorly
studied line against the king's ending a
line that most Kings Indian players sort
of pass by without looking at too
carefully it's the averback variation
named after uh the recently deceased
Yuri ever back and it starts with the
move Bishop E2
now those of you well versed in King's
Indian Theory will know that the
classical main line is Knight F3 and
Bishop B2 or Bishop E2 and Knight F3 in
the averback you immediately develop the
C1 Bishop to G5
now the abber back is I think very good
because it has a very specific idea
Bishop G5 is not just a development move
it's also a prophylactic move what is it
prophylaxis against an rip Yuri AB
Rebecca was the oldest living GM
who can tell me what Bishop G5 actually
prevents prevents is too strong of a
word it discourages at E5 yeah so the
first trap is that E5 doesn't lose the
game but it does lose a pawn and leads
to a terrible end game I'll show that
after the game
so after H6 we have two moves we can
play Bishop H4
but if memory serves me right H6 is not
that common because this does create a
Target
which we can later attack and if I
remember correctly the main move is to
drop the bishop back to E3
the idea is to preserve pressure on the
H6 Pawn we can later follow up with
Queen D2
and the pod on H6 could also serve as a
hook for a potential Pawn storm and you
shouldn't rule out a pawn storm if
you've seen your fair share of King's
Indian games you know that it's
absolutely not automatic for white to
bring the night out in Castle kingside
recently people have been playing with
the king in the center a lot more
because the center is so well protected
and if you keep the king in the center
then you have this idea of launching a
pawn storm against Black's King it's
just basically going straight for
checkmate uh G4 and H4 and G5 and
there's a ton of games that that are
incredibly one-sided where white does
that and black doesn't know how to react
and if black is not incredibly well
versed in how to fight this Pawn storm
and these ideas you know you're just
gonna blow people off the board every
time yeah of course now E5 is possible
so the downside of putting the bishop on
E3 is that E5 is now possible
but it's not the end of the world like
black playing E5 isn't you know such a
great accomplishment it's just sort of a
a typical Kings Indian move why not
Bishop E3 for the semi over back well I
think inducing H6 is a good idea for
white this Pawn being on H6 rather than
on H7 typically favors white yeah now of
course we close the center with D5
that's the whole point
the whole point of this line is that you
close down the center and by closing
down the center you're basically untying
your hands for King side action with the
center closed you don't have to divert
as many resources to maintaining the
stability of the center and you can
focus your attention on the two flanks
all right so D5 is on the board and A5
by our opponent which is another very
typical King's Indian move the idea of
course is to prevent b2b4 and typically
A5 is followed up with a classic Knight
maneuver to C5 either through D7 or
through A6 black is heading for C5 with
the knight in order to put pressure on
the E4 pawn and just position the Knight
on a good Square
so again another branching off point
white has several ways to approach this
position but I think it's very much in
the spirit of the averback the semi ever
back to go directly for Black's throat
and we're gonna make a move that you
know if you haven't seen too many kings
Indian games will look totally wild too
it'll look completely in violation of
opening principles it'll seem like a
coffee house move but in reality it's
usually the computer's top suggestion
these types of positions and that is not
H4 although H4 is also very much
possible but directly G for G2 G4
no F4 is bad because that allows black
to open up the center and activate the
Bishops you almost never go F4 with
white in these types of positions full
send G4 let's go
let's go
so a couple of things what is the idea
of G4 well the idea of G4 is pretty
obvious we are trying to send our pawns
at blackskang open up the H file ideally
and use the H6 Pawn as a hook and when I
say that word hook I hope everybody
knows what I mean it's a pawn that's
Advanced past its initial Square which
can be used as kind of dynamite to
explode an open file and make it easier
to open a file
otherwise it would be a lot harder to
open the H file and it would take a lot
longer
so a couple of things that we're going
to have to be
mindful of
one is we want to make sure mental note
to self keep the E4 Pawn protected if
Black's Knight lands on C5 we are going
to want to play the move F3 in order to
solidify the E4 bundle the last thing we
want is to lose our main anchor pod on
e4 if the Center opens up then our
entire strategy is going to come
crashing down so so the success of G4
and H4
is fully contingent on us being able to
keep the center as closed as possible
and that's why if you're on the black
side of these types of positions one
very common idea that not everybody
knows is to push the seep on up to C6
trying to chip away at white center and
open up the queen side a little bit
maybe prepare later Queen B6 black
cannot
black cannot fall asleep here because
this attack is coming really really
quickly
what about taking the Knight on C5 so
hint a piece of advice you almost never
take the Knight on C5 in the king's
Indian with the dark squirt Bishop there
are situations where you do but in maybe
80 percent of cases it's a very bad idea
to give up your dark squared Bishop why
is that well it should be clear why that
is just from looking at this position
the dark squared Bishop is an integral
attacking piece it's it's a piece that
Lords over the entire position it's
controlling squares on the queen side
for example after C6 it's preventing the
queen from coming to B6 that's a good
defensive role but most importantly it's
supervising the king Side Pawn storm
it's controlling the G5 and H6 squares
it makes H4 and G5 a lot more effective
it allows us to play G5 if necessary
without H4
so the bishop is just fulfilling a ton
of important roles it's a Swiss army
knife and giving it up not only weakens
the dark squares tremendously but as
I'll show you after the game when the
d-pawn captures on C5 it gives black the
D6 Square which could be used for the
other night
I've beaten plenty of players who give
up the Dark Sword Bishop for the Knight
on C5
Knight A6 indeed
Knight A6 indeed
okay so do we need to prevent the knight
from coming to C5 no that's exactly what
I was just explaining it's okay for the
Knight to come to C5 because we can
protect the E4 Pawn with f2f3
so we can continue our King side
campaign
with the move H5 H4 launched the second
Pawn why not G5 immediately yet G5
immediately would have been also very
good G5 immediately would have also been
very good I agree completely
but the added benefit of playing H4 is
that after g5h takes G5 we can take back
with the H Pawn and to open up the
h-file 97.
all right so now
well what do we do now now we have
another pretty Pleasant choice
we can most certainly play the move H5
and then black is going to close down
the king side with G5 and that may seem
like a bad thing for white but in fact
from a positional standpoint it's not
because after H5 G5 the square on F5
becomes a a gaping weakness and we can
try to bring our Knight there that
becomes a very much coveted Outpost for
the night
so what do we do now we can play Queen
E2 we can play H5 let's weigh the pros
and cons of each
so if we play Queen D2 black is going to
respond with King H7
then we can try to the problem is that
it's very hard to open the king side
Knight D7 was a very smart move
so after Queen D2 King H7 it's a classic
situation where if if we play G5 then
black plays H5 if we play H5 then black
plays G5
so the best thing for us to do I think
is to switch from tactical play to
positional play
and to in fact play the move H5
induce G5 and then try to get the G1
Knight around to F5
sounds like a very hard thing to do but
there is a typical maneuver in such
positions that allows us to do it pretty
efficiently we go Knight F3
notice that we're exploiting the
temporary fact that the Knight on D7
blocks the bishop right otherwise we
wouldn't have been able to go Knight F3
also notice we're deliberately not
putting our Pawn on F3 which would make
it a lot harder to navigate this Knight
over to F5
so our overall strategy is going to be
the following we are going to get the
Knight to G3
presumably black is going to move the
Knight away from D7 so that the bishop
controls the F5 Square we're going to
wait for the most opportune moment to
put the Knight on F5 but in the meantime
we are going to switch the center of our
attention from the King side to the
queen side and one of the biggest
misconceptions in the king's Indian from
the white side is that white can never
attack on the queen side you think in
the classical variation white attacks on
the queen side black attacks on the king
side but in these average lines most
people think that if they don't succeed
in checkmating black on the king side
then we're somehow screwed and black is
going to murder us on the queen side
totally not true in fact white has the
superiority kind of on both flanks
Knight F6 so as we predicted
as we predicted black moves the night
out of D7
what do we do now well we make a move
that suits both purposes
we play Knight D2
and then we play Knight F1 and Knight G3
notice again that the
Pawn on G4 is very well protected
okay Knight C5
so now that we've gotten the Knight now
that we've gotten the Knight out of G1
we can play the move F3 very safely
because we're not interfering in the
night's path from F1 to G3 does that
make sense
notice that Queen C2 would have been a
blunder because we would have taken our
eyes off the G4 Pawn
so there's an order of operations here a
sequence of moves that you have to
follow carefully so that everything you
know the Machinery of the position Works
to Perfection are we worried about our
King safety again we're not worried
about our King safety as long as we can
keep the center closed because it
doesn't matter whether we have pawns
around our king or not if the center is
closed black doesn't have the tools to
approach our King so our next two moves
are very likely yes C6 is very good our
opponent is doing everything you're
supposed to do with the on the black
side here but weakening the F5 Square
generally means that black is going to
be worse for the rest of the game do we
need to react to this do we need to play
D takes C6 or Bishop takes C5 no and no
again White's job is to keep the center
closed Black's job is to try to open it
it's not it's C6 and C takes D5 doesn't
really do all that much to open the
center we can safely continue with our
overall plan and continue getting this
Knight around to G3
why don't we take the C5 Knight well I
explained that a little bit earlier
all right and I'll talk about that more
after the game we just generally don't
want to give away our dark switch bishop
and create permanent weaknesses on the
dark squares this bishop is going to be
a very important piece trust me
hopefully I'll have a chance to
demonstrate that in the course of the
game
C takes D5 an interesting moment occurs
here we're gonna take back with the c
pawn and keep the structure symmetrical
but there are certain conditions under
which you can consider the move e takes
D5
there are certain conditions under which
you consider he takes D5 mostly if you
have the E4 Square under control the
flaw in E takes D5 here is that black
can advance the pawn to E4 not only
opening up the center but also reopening
the dark squared bishop and that is the
last thing we want to allow so we play
CD
now you might say well okay the C file
is now open doesn't black benefit from
that can't black play like Bishop D7 and
Rook C8 yeah that's generally what black
does in these types of positions but our
Queen side is perfectly well defended
it's not that if black gets a rook to C8
you know anything cataclysmic happens
why not take with a knight mostly it's
it's just because the Knight on C3 is a
very also very important piece why is it
a very important piece well among other
things that is discouraging and
preventing black from pushing the pawn
out to B5 and launching a pawn storm of
his own so the Knight is just a general
anchoring piece it's defending E4 it's
protecting D5 it's defending the B5
Square it's a good piece to keep around
Bishop D7 okay this does not threaten
the move B5 just yet because we have two
Defenders on that square so what can we
continue to do well we can continue to
carry out our main plan
and put the Knight on G3 and finally
after like seven moves
we have accomplished our main idea to
put the Knight on G3
now what sorts of long-term things do we
need to pay attention to here well our
top goal our most you know the top item
on our wish list is to exchange what
pair of pieces who can tell me what
minor piece exchange favors white
tremendously what is our top goal
yeah not the dark squared Bishop no no
no the dark squared Bishops I mean this
bishop is terrible it's a big Pawn the
light squared Bishops if we can trade
the light squared Bishops we will be
able to put an uncontested Knight on F5
and that is a huge deal a knight on F5
in these types of positions it just will
terrorize Black's position
Queen B6 attacking the B2 Pawn we need
to defend that pawn what is the best way
to defend it I know a lot of you are
probably tempted to play B3 but B3
creates a pawn hook on the queen side it
allows black to stir up some unpleasant
complications with A4 it also loosens up
the Knight on C3 we don't want to do
that either we want to play the move
Queen D2 nice harmonious connect the
Rooks defend the bishop Queen D2
accomplishes a lot of good things at the
same time you should also keep an eye
out for Bishop takes G5 I know some of
you pointed this out earlier I was
impressed Bishop takes G5 is a
frequently missed tactic in these
positions because black starts assuming
that the king is always going to be safe
Bishop takes G5 could lead to a quick
Checkmate after H takes G5 H6 I don't
think it's a threat just yet although it
it is a borderline threat like we could
consider it if black isn't careful
so of course black can play Knight H7
and protect G5 we're not winning this
game in the next three moves
what is the next set of things that we
want to accomplish well we need to look
at our position and identify the things
that are not working perfectly and try
to make them better one of the things
that I think we can improve is the
positioning of our King
is our King unsafe no but there is a
very nice Square for the king such that
the king is out of the way and we don't
have to worry about the king catching
second-hand smoke from when the queen
side opens up and that square is G2 yeah
we can put it on F2 but when the king is
on F2 it's still susceptible to these
tactics related to Knight takes G4
Knight takes C4 and I'm talking here in
the long run you have to understand this
because if you're thinking what do you
mean the G4 and e-force pawns are well
defended we're talking here about 10 15
moves down the line Rook ACA okay well
we can start journeying our King out to
out to uh G2
and the reason that I want to do it
through F2 by the way
is that I want the Rooks to be connected
if something happens and we need to
bring our Rook into the game urgently
we can do so without playing King G2 of
course we are forfeiting our ability to
play Bishop takes G5 because
we're temporarily putting our King In
Harm's Way why not Castle great question
we can still Castle but I want to leave
open the possibility of Bishop takes G5
I actually want this Rook to stay on H1
in order to make bishop takes G5 a
long-term possibility and in such
positions with a closed Center you want
to apply maximum pressure which often
means you want to keep open the
possibility of certain tactical ideas to
keep your opponent on their toes
wasn't Bishop takes G5 winning I don't
think it was Bishop G5 hg5 I didn't see
a clear follow-up we could have maybe
tried Bishop G5 but
I think we might have the opportunity to
do so later in the game A4
okay so here
what black probably wants is to play A3
A3 what does A3 do A3 essentially
induces B3 which as we've already
discussed loosens up the Knight on
on on C3 and why is it bad that the
Knight on C3 is loose because there's a
rook on C8 and black can make a move
like Queen before and if you're
experienced in these positions you will
know that there is a very nice way to
prevent black from playing A3 to take
the sting out of it does anybody see
what move I'm talking about
so if you think about it if black plays
A3 we want to meet that move with B4
pinning the Knight on C5
so if we play A3 ourselves I totally
understand where you're coming from but
you're creating a gaping hole on the B3
Square which is okay but after A3 there
are tactics or black plays Knight B3
immediately counter-attacking the queen
so the subtle move here is Rook a to B1
again you might how do I find a move
like this if you're experienced in these
positions this is a move that is sort of
second nature with the idea of meeting
A3 with B4 and that wins the night
this move is necessary because we need
to protect the B4 Square
so the way I see this game going Queen
A5 very good move our opponent is
demonstrating extremely Keen knowledge
of of King's Indian ideas but now
I think we are almost ready to play
Bishop takes G5 I think we need to
consider it here let's think about
Bishop takes G5 for a hot second shall
we
let's calculate
hunker down this is gonna be
complicated but I think you guys can
handle this bishop takes G5
H takes G5
H6 which is of course the main idea
and after Bishop h8
the problem in that position is that if
we take on G5 with check the black king
can find a very nice hiding spot on H7
so we need to somehow open up the H file
so that the other Rook on B1 can later
jump into the game with Rook H1 so I am
heavily implying a particular kind of
move this move occurs after Bishop G5
hgh6 Bishop h8 yeah we have to play H7
black is forced to play Knight takes H7
and there I think we have a critical
move I think we have a beautiful
follow-up move
uh which wins the game for white in that
position so I think we can safely go for
Bishop takes G5
I think we can
safely go for Bishop takes G5
note also that I briefly considered
Knight F takes E4 check I just made sure
that black doesn't have any crazy
shenanigans
uh with Knight takes C4
the counter play well the counter play
comes too late right the counter play is
coming too late black with the move
Queen A5 black essentially indicates
that he wants to push the pawn down to
B4 and there isn't enough time for that
we're already checkmating the black king
here
all right H takes G5 and of course we
play H6
of course we play H6 Bishop h8
H7 check again why not Queen takes G5
very tempting move because the king
hides away on H7 I think even there
oh wait a second wait a minute just give
me a moment I actually just spotted a
cool idea
I actually just spotted a cool idea give
me a second let me let me try to
calculate it
because if this works it's like an
immortal concept
but I don't think it quite does the
trick and I don't think it's necessary
I don't think it's necessary I think H7
is a much simpler way to win I'll show
you what I was thinking after the game
but let's stick to the uh let's stick to
our guns H7
and Rook takes H7 without this move
the entire combination would fall apart
what was a necessary component of this
entire combination it was actually
putting our King on F2 folks without the
king being on F2 this would not work why
who can tell me what the best move is
now
is it Rook H1 is it something else
it's not Rook H1
why is it not Rook H1 because black can
play King G6 and defend the pawn on G5
so as tempting as it is to deliver a
check here no no no we play Queen takes
u5 cutting the king off the G file and
on the next move we drag our Rook over
to H1 with Checkmate the black has only
one way to Stave off mate that is to
somehow intercept the Queen's access to
G8 there is only one move which is
Bishop G7 but there the win is very
simple we play Rook H1 Force the king
back to G8 and who sees the winning move
in that position who sees the winning
move in that position this is very very
nice yeah Knight H5 excellent
note that in that position we're not
only threatening Queen takes G7 but also
threatening Knight F6 mate this one is
over
what's crazy is that after age six I'll
let you guys in on a secret I spotted a
crazy defensive resource for black I
actually think black could have held on
with a ridiculous defensive resource
after which black is still much worse
but maybe surviving and we'll get to
this moment of the post game analysis
I'll show you what I'm talking about
anyways uh we could also start with that
H5 there's nothing wrong with that
we can also start with Knight H1 Knight
H5
but
I think this is more precise it leads to
a more forcing mate
and it's all over Knight H5
nh5
and the game is over there's two main
threats all the black can do is give us
a meaningless check on D3 or on e4 it
doesn't change anything the white king
is perfectly safe resigns and we win
great game
great game only 27 moves and yet a lot
of things to talk about
Hopefully this wasn't too bad of an
alternative to playing Magnus
all right
so let's analyze King's Indian E4 D6 to
give you a sense of how many variations
you have to know if you want to play The
King's Indian successfully with black
so in order of an approximate order of
popularity the main line is Knight F3
and Bishop E2 this is what's called the
classical main line it's also called the
Orthodox variation and you might be
familiar with this even if you're not a
king's Indian player black plays Knight
C6 D5 Knight E7 and this is the start of
a ridiculous amount of theory hopefully
most of you are familiar with this
position there's the bayonet attack with
B4 there's Knight E1
you know we could spend hours on that
position alone
then there are uh lines that are almost
as popular as the main line there's the
makagonov variation which is an early H3
this move H3 can be played in like 50
different positions and all of them lead
to different lines so for example you
can play H3 and Bishop G5
you can play H3 and Bishop B3 you can
play H3 and Knight F3 and all of these
are different and the theory of these
lines are different
you could play the four pawns attack
with F4 very reputable line dangerous if
black doesn't know what to do F3 is of
course the same-ish variation I have
been playing this in previous speedrun
games
there is the Yasser sarawan variation
Bishop D3
there is the Andrew Tang line Knight ge2
and you could play F3 and transpose into
the same-ish or you could play an
independent line and get the Knight over
to G3 I have faced this line myself more
than once
um and then there are a bunch of new
lines there's Bishop B2 and Bishop E3
which Karo has been playing successfully
this is a line that has taken the Chess
World by storm almost everybody is
playing this with white against the
king's Indian this is all of the fashion
I don't necessarily think it's the best
line against the king's Indian but you
guys know how fashion works it's like
Hikaru plays the line or mvl plays line
then everybody's playing it and Bishop
E2 Bishop E3 is a very venomous very
venomous continuation
and of course there's the ever back so
that's already something like eight or
nine lines
uh and the ever back it has been around
for a very long time it's it's an old
school line
and it's one of those variations which
doesn't receive too much coverage in
King's Indian books
it you know it's not too well analyzed
by people and it's it's very dangerous
uh I've faced the hour back several
times and I've gotten worse positions
basically every time as black in the
king's getting a little bit of History
the first time that the averback was
played was in the year 1930
by a guy named Eric Anderson averback
was the one two three four fifth player
to play it averback played it in 1952
and then 1953 was also played by a
Yugoslav Grandmaster borislav ifkov in
1951. uh so a lot of good players played
this line in the 50s
and it's been around for half a century
and
the main point of this move
as I explained this to prevent E5
E5 is bad because after d-e-d-e
queen queen 68 Rook 68
you have which move
who can tell me what the move is here
and white score is 81 percent this one's
the exchange yeah 95 95. of course is
the whole point of the line and black is
in huge trouble huge trouble either you
lose an exchange
either you lose an exchange or
you can play Knight B to D7 but now you
lose a pawn with a terrible position if
memory serves me right white can also
Castle just look at the pressure on
Black's position this is horrible
so a lot of people miss this a lot of
people aren't aware of this and so you
can win a lot of games just like that
so for this reason the most popular way
to play against the outer back is either
to prepare the move E5 and the way that
people typically prepare it is to push
is to is to slide the queen to E8 this
move should make perfect sense to you
you're preparing E5 you're getting out
of the pin preemptively but also it's
very popular to strike with the benoni
idea and play C5 if you're a king's
Indian player you have to be comfortable
you know in some variations to play C5
rather than E5 and after C5 white plays
D5 here there is the Banco Gambit idea
with B5 this is not a good line white is
better here
and there is the move there's the movie
six uh which is what a lot of modern
books recommend but I've analyzed this
very carefully and I always feel like
black is a little bit uncomfortable here
I always feel like black is a little bit
uncomfortable here so anyways we won't
get too bogged down in theory H6 is a
viable move but after Bishop B3 I think
white is already considered to be better
I think white is already considered to
be better so E5 D5 A5 this is all
standard fare and G4 I'm checking
reference is not the main line the main
move here according to opening Explorer
is in fact the more traditional Knight
F3
but the problem with Knight F3
let's not get too bogged on in theory is
that black has Knight G4 and black can
quickly push through F5 this is why I
don't like
playing the early Knight F3 I think G4
is more in the spirit of this variation
in my opinion
so G4 Knight A6 H4
some of you were pointing out that G5 is
an interesting alternative it most
certainly is HG is forced we play Bishop
takes G5 and now you shove the pawn down
to H5 I think white is better here as
well but often it's not as simple as it
appears black has counter play of their
own for example black can play the move
C6 here
and if you play H4 the queen comes out
to P6 attacking B2
and if you play Queen D2 the knights
coming to C5 so it's it's not as
one-sided as it might seem black has
ways to quickly engineer queenside
counter play why is H takes G5 Force
because if you move the Knight I take on
H6 with devastating effect
in any case in any case
Knight A6 we decided on the more
traditional H4 thank you Ben for the
raid
and Knight F6 to D7
a good move a good move there are still
two games in the database at this point
a 2500 against the 2100 and
correspondence and two twenty three
hundredths have faced this position
we play the move H5 and this I think is
the move that most people would struggle
with the most people would struggle to
find because once H4 and G4 is on the
board you think okay I want a Checkmate
black but in the king's Indian as white
you want to be able to switch gears from
tactical to positional as I explained
the idea of H5 is to create a massive
weakness on the F5 square and I learned
this lesson the hard way I had a game
all the way back when I was 1800 where
something very very similar happened and
I spent the rest of the game suffering
even though I held a draw
you know I held a draw I spent the rest
of the game suffering here is that game
all the way back in 2005.
all the way back in 2005.
so
all the way back in 2005 I had okay
Bishop D3 this is the Yasser Saron
variation
and Watch What Happens
Bishop C2 now he castles King's side
which is a slightly different kind of
line
and here I decided to play G5
that was a big mistake right this is a
very instructive mistake in the king's
Indian you normally don't go G5 you play
for F5 but I didn't know this I was
still inexperienced Knight to H2
to prevent the move G4
B3 and then he goes G4 himself and I was
so surprised seeing this movie what is
this guy doing he's castled kingside and
he's playing G4 but because the position
is so closed it's incredibly hard for
black to exploit the move G4 thing King
h8 and who can tell well I guess the
notation is on the screen Knight F1 and
Knight G3 just like we did in the game
he puts the then an F5 and I spent the
rest of the game struggling immensely
white was completely winning in this
game so so this is a a standard idea in
the king's Indian that you have to be
well aware of
band with a sub
and we basically do the same exact thing
in this game we play Knight F3
then we play road to FM thank you for
the sub then we play Knight C2
then we play F3 we literally just
execute the plan like a monkey we get
the Knight around to G3
C6 Knight F1 cdcd
Bishop D7 we got our Knight to G3 the
concept here is the importance of
appreciating long-term factors in chess
okay because you look at this you say
okay but I can't get my knight to F5
black plays Bishop takes F5 but that's
not the only important thing in chess
you have to also think okay but if the
light squared Bishops at any point
disappear from the board I'm going to
have a potential game-winning asset in
hanging over the F5 Square so this idea
of putting pressure and concentrating on
the short term as well as the long term
also notice that B5 is not possible
and Bishop B5 would have been
a serious candidate move on the next
move if our opponent hadn't gone Queen
B6 I'll do Torino thank you for the 11.
Queen D2 rook ac8 and now the
game-winning plan deciding to get our
King over to G2 we play King F2
the plan was we get our King to G2 we
make sure it's safe and then we turn our
attention over to the queen side is A4
here a move I don't like A4 because it
weakens the B3 Square I don't see the
point in making a weakness this big
thank you the chestnut live
so we play King F2
and after A4 we play this very important
prophylactic move Rook ab1
the idea is to meet A3 with B4 that
would win the Knight
and after Queen A5 I made that point a
couple of moves ago in such positions
you have to always be aware of potential
tactics and this is a big reason why
people don't see tactics is they assume
that just because something doesn't work
in one position you you can stop
considering it but you have to make
mental notes to yourself throughout the
game and say this is something I want to
consider this is something I want to
consider and basically on every move you
want to reconsider whether the tactic
works that's what I did here and we
found the perfect opportunity for Bishop
takes u5 so yeah after H6 I realized
that I had missed a beautiful counter
tactic sorry I realized that I'd missed
a beautiful counter tactic this counter
tactic involves creating space for the
bishop on G7 by sacrificing this Knight
with check that's by the way why the
king would be so much better placed on
G2 I pointed this out during the game
and after FG Bishop F6 somehow black is
still surviving Knight H5 the bishop
drops back to d8 maybe white is winning
here somehow but I actually don't think
so I think black is doing all right
so it's entirely possible
that the best move would have indeed
been to play King G2 first wait for
black to play B5 I was getting anxious
about this but this is not dangerous
even if black plays B4
we can just continue grabbing stuff on
the king side and this is completely
winning Bishop takes H6 BC and queen G5
uh so this is all very very
straightforward
so we should have waited we should have
played King G2 and patiently carried out
the entire plan before grabbing on G5
computer claims equal yeah Bishop takes
G5 is a serious mistake the computer
gives plus 1.5 after King G2
and apparently Rook A8 here or King H7
and white is clearly better we can also
try to trade Queens by dropping the
snipe back to D1 we can drop the Knight
back to D1 trade queens and then try to
get this other Knight around to F5 as
well
so King F2 yeah Bishop G5 is a mistake
hgh6 and it is because of Knight takes
G4 check
that this idea was Believe It or Not
premature white is still slightly better
after King G2
I mean we still have a lot of assets
here we can go Rook F1 and Knight F5 so
it's not like this is all that great for
black
but it was a little bit impatient but
after Bishop h8 H7 the game is over
Knight H7 Rook H7 the last chance for
black would have been to play a move
like F6
but after Rook H1 can you really blame
black for not wanting this position and
guess what guess what the best move is
here it's actually Bishop B5
that old idea I mentioned now sacrifices
a piece but the night is so powerful
that this would have led to a winning
position
in any case King H7 Queen G5 ends the
game immediately Bishop G7 or H1 Knight
H5 and mate is Unstoppable so takeaways
from this game the outer back is a very
underrated weapon against the King City
and it prevents E5
uh do not be afraid to push pawns on the
king side with you and do not be afraid
to keep your king in the center when you
feel that the center is closed and it's
very difficult to reopen
and then this G4 H4 idea is uh very
dangerous in the king's Indian
but then Switching gears from tactical
play to positional play we played G4 and
H4 in order to try to deliver Checkmate
but once the Knight moves away from F6
where we realized the Checkmate isn't
very possible and so we switched to
positional gear so we weakened the F5
Square we get our Knight around and we
very patiently nurture the advantage
um hopefully you found this game
useful hope you enjoyed and I'm going to
call it a day here folks so thank you
for watching thank you everybody for the
support and that was a nice game I
really like the way that I've been
playing the last couple of speed on
games we've gotten a lot of instructive
content out uh one more shout out that I
do have a YouTube channel and every sub
every sub counts so if you like the
content you like what I do you would be
doing me a massive solid by throwing
your name in the ring and subscribing
we're trying to reach 300K so I'm far
from the biggest Channel but you know I
do my best it's a two-man operation and
uh you know just want to thank everybody
for being awesome and super supportive
and the comments are always massively
wholesome and make my day so thank you
everybody
thank you everybody for hanging out see
everybody later bye
[Music]